so dating apps have been a little
bizarre then there are men on there who
like don't get the point and are like oh
I'm looking for a quarantine Bay to come
over like that's not what this is for
that this is not the time for that hi
I'm Francesca I'm Mike it's destiny I am
in quarantine and I am single and I am
single
currently quarantined and I'm also
single there's my dog in the back
he's my current boyfriend so today I'm
going to be trying this new app called
quarantine together it's not an app like
tinder tinder texts you directly go to
this website and you fill out your
information they like pair you with
someone you don't get to see pictures of
them you don't know their name kind of
felt like love is blind which I love
just to get a little more information
about how this whole app works we
reached out to one of the creators of
the app just to hear from him how this
whole thing is supposed to go I'm Daniel
Ahmadi zadeh I'm one of the founders of
quarantine together
quarantines together is an app that text
you every single day to see if you've
washed your hands or if your snake
indoors and if you reply back yes then
you get rewarded with a match then you
have 20 minutes to exchange in a text
conversation with them it's completely
anonymous so you don't know their number
they don't know your number and if all
goes well if you want to continue
learning more about this person we send
you a link to a private video call the
underlying problem that we're solving
because loneliness problem is a lack of
human connection problem even if you
have a handful of people and create your
own little quarantine together you just
catch up with one another every day at 6
o'clock it just will help us all get
through this I like that they are trying
to raise awareness to stay inside which
is like what we should be doing to like
help flatten the curve the idea of just
having a nice conversation with somebody
without necessarily worrying about what
they look like and I'm not worrying
about what I look like sounds kind of
nice if we don't make it
romantically maybe we can be friends on
LinkedIn like I don't know we can be
professional buddies I don't say this
without sounding terrible I don't really
need more friends like I have a good
amount of friends let's see how this
goes
okay so I just got a text that says hi
destiny this is quarantined together did
you wash your hands or stay indoors
today are you available to chat with
your match in the next few minutes reply
yes if so I wonder how they're matching
me like what how is this my match like
based off what criteria area code like I
don't know as I'm sitting here minding
my own business eating my quarantine
ice-cream I get a text message from an
unknown number replied yes to connect
well match you in five minutes
smiley face yes I should reply yes the
meantime I'll just keep enjoying my ice
cream so it was around 6 when I got the
text saying that I was matched with this
guy named guys I have my first
connection as Michael to this message to
connect introduce yourselves
I just got matched it says destiny meet
so I said hello
someone I know I'll put it there this is
both of our first times every was in
quarantine together it's not shaved his
face normally he's clean-shaven I wrote
I mean I don't think anyone is shaving
their face these days I have started let
it slide I'm trying to this guy from New
York um conversations a little dry he's
like what have you watched on Netflix
and I was like why I've been watching
all the shows Tiger king for example and
he was like oh I can't really get into
that and I was like oh ok so I don't
think we have much in common so he asked
me where I was from and I said I was
born here in LA when I said that he
replied oh I'm from New York and I was
like oh ok this is weird so I asked him
how his quarantine was going and he
actually said that he is an essential
worker and I was just like immediately
just like concerned for him and his like
well-being during this time but he
seemed it to be like taking it in stride
I haven't really learned that much about
him in the 30 minutes we've been
chatting they just sent the link for an
audio call and I asked him like hey did
you want to do that like and no response
so I'm just like ok
okay now we're gonna money involved I
think I don't know if cameras the
situation that we want right now but
audio sounds good so I'm just gonna
click allow yes I do see you know Allah
I'm glad this by this work this is I
really didn't know this technology was
gonna do what it needed to do
so yeah house how's your quarantine bin
have you just been inside can you see me
you're handsome
I think this quarantine is scary it's
like I'm like extra paranoid now you're
married you're my first time and maybe
my only time so it's been like 10
minutes since I asked if he wanted to
use the chat thing he has not responded
so I'm gonna take that doesn't know I
will give him the benefit of the doubt
he may be jaded by a dating app
sometimes when you're on dating app so
long you can just be like tired of the
small talk in the mundane um but I'm
brand new to this I'm like hi what are
you doing are you from what's your name
yeah it was a lot more fun than I
expected I was definitely worried that
they were no gay men on it everyone he
is not my like typical type but he was
like very nice and just very chill and I
think that's just all anyone can really
ask or it gets really cool but you can
be matched with someone anywhere and
specifically that you can match with
someone without ever seeing what they
look like I don't know if I could say I
enjoyed talking to it was nice meeting
someone new so once he found out I was
in LA the conversation kind of like
really dried out so I feel like if the
app matched people that were close sir
then maybe people would be more
interested because it seems more
realistic that you'll actually meet them
I have been lonely and this was so it's
a really helpful distraction I think
this app definitely helps alleviate some
loneliness that people might be having I
just feel a lot more energized just like
talking to someone else will I ever find
my mate
is he out there are you out there if
you're out there man call me fine you
know where to find me please stay safe
wash your hands
[Music]
[Music]